ああよしよしよしいいぞよし
よし先生朝の会はまだですあ適当にやっ
といてくれよしよし行け行けあそういば笑
はマラソン大会だマラソン大会こんな寒い
のにマラソン大会とかバカじゃないですか
子供は風の子元気の子だろ今からとっくん
だマラソンに必要なのは脚力この
サイクリングマシンを全力でこぐんだ先生
は出かけてくるお前らちゃんとやるよ
頑張れ頑張れ頑張れ頑張れ頑張れ頑張れ頑
頑張れ頑張れ頑張れ頑
頑よしよしよしよしもあもあよしよし
あいつらが電気を供給してないなゲーム
やり放題だよしよしよしも
よし
[音楽]
はあお前らちゃんとこげ
ダクはり続けるには強靭な心配能力が必要
だそのストローに息を吹き続けるん
[音楽]
だよしよし
よしこれで快適にゲームができるぞよよし
よしなんだこれ
[音楽]
はほらそんな弱な間感想できない
ぞ今日の練習は終わり明日はもっと厳しい
ぞマラソン大会の優勝商品はゲームだお前
らもっと頑張れ
[音楽]
ゲームもしかしてゲームってマリオカート
マさあ今日もトレーニングだお前ら今日は
ちゃんとやる
よさてとゲームするかよしよし行け行け
よしよしお今日はなかなか切れないぞ
うわ
[拍手]
けあ
あっちさ電力送りすぎだ自転車を止めろ
うわうわ
止めろ俺がいから止めて
くれ先生を殺すけか
へ今日は待にったマラソン大会だ
それじゃあ1け
はい今日足の調子悪いから適当に走ろと俺
もやる気ないから適当に走ろうじゃあ
みんなで一緒にゆっくり走ろうよいいね
そうしよう1てよーい
ドンと違う
じゃん今日のためにショートカットの
マップを作ってきたんだこっちだ
[音楽]
最短ルートでゴール
だやすここは正しいルートじゃないよなみ
道を間違えまし
たくそこうなっ
たらこれで大幅ショートカットだ
それのショートカットも気
しねいい加減ショートカットを
諦めろ
くそみんな早い
[音楽]
よこれはなるほどショートカットにすれば
いいの
かできたこれで私もショートカット何して
んだ
ここが救水所か水はどこだこれを
飲め何すんだよいいからこれに
着替えろ何なんですかこれはさあこっから
はリアルマリオカートだあ
もうす待てくそこれでもくれ
[音楽]
くそこれでどう
だお先
待てスターだ雷だ
行け何行け全員ぶ
これでマリカは私だだよ
[拍手]
[音楽]
おりゃ優勝は
やすスには優勝商品のゲームをあげよう
やったおめでとう
えこれがゲームゲームと言ったら将棋だろ
より将の方が好きなんだよなマカじゃない
のかよ
ママちゃちゃチャンネル登録チャンネル
登録チャンネル登録よろしくチャンネル
登録チャンネル登録チャンネル登録
よろしくはチン
[音楽]
ンネル録